you uh got an education of browns you're
somebody is amazing because as an
olympian and an olympic coach you always
emphasize kind of balance and
educational
uh all of that side of life so
developing your brain too so you are an
olympic medalist
a coach of olympic medalists your
business owner so successful in all
these domains
so i have to ask what advice would you
give to young people today high school
judo age high school college undergrad
how to be successful in their career or
just in life in general how to
live a life they can be proud of
i think you have to be true to yourself
you have to decide what it is you really
want to do with your life like
and it's hard because when i grew up i
didn't know i was going to be successful
when i was you know when i was young i
didn't know i was going to be an olympic
medalist i certainly did envision myself
owning a couple of companies that
that makes their living exclusively for
martial arts or judo because that wasn't
really an opportunity when i was a kid
but i've created that opportunity i
would just say that like pick something
that you're passionate about
you know i was stuck in a career before
where i wasn't passionate about it and
it was my wife who said you know jimmy
if you can figure out
how to
make your living exclusively from
martial arts
you know where your brain and your heart
and your passion is all towards one
thing that you really like
then you'll be successful and i left the
job i had three kids i was working for
monster.com i was in internet marketing
and i was working for that company great
company nothing wrong with the company
but sitting behind the desk from eight
til five and then i get to go to judo
from six until nine at night
you know my whole day is tied up doing
something that i'm really not passionate
about she said if you know
if you can figure out how to make money
from your dojo and other things judo
related
then i think you'll be successful and so
she's the one that my wife marie gave me
that advice and i would give that to
others find something that you love
doing where it doesn't feel like work
something you're passionate about and if
the opportunity doesn't exist how to
make money on it you can create the
opportunity be resourceful figure it out
don't don't let anybody tell you you
can't do it right i i didn't know that i
could have a 200 person judo school that
only taught judo because that really
didn't exist in this country
you know that it actually charges money
like jiu jitsu charges right we're
talking not there's plenty of clubs out
there that charge 10 bucks a month that
might have 100 people but there's not
many that you know with the tuition is
150 a month having 200 people so that's
a successful business
but it wasn't done before but be
passionate about it understand you're
going to fail
understand you're going to get knocked
down beat up
right there's going to be dark days but
you got to persevere you got to believe
in yourself you got to have a plan
you have to be willing to learn from
other people
and that's what i did i i i didn't know
it i brought somebody in to tell me what
am i doing wrong like look from the
outside what do you see
okay great then you got to be willing to
change you're going to be willing to
adapt
you know and
i think listening believing in myself
and you know creating opportunity and
the other thing is
helping others
something i always did in my in my
judo life
and in my business life
if somebody came to me and asked for
help with hey man is there something you
can do to help me i'm trying to get this
thing started you know i'm trying to get
this this this dojo off the ground or
i'm trying to run this event series or
you know i
i was creative and trying to figure out
a way to help them make it work because
if that really was their dream and i
could help them do their dream
i felt like that person would then
give nothing but good good comments
about us good good like they'll remember
it forever they become like family and
they're the best advocates for your
business ever and so
the kids that i taught at my dojo are
treated that way the people that work
for me get treated that way the people
that
my customers that i work with and
building their
dojos get treated that way people that
ran tournaments whether it was
grappler's quest years ago and helping
that guy with a full set of mats for his
brian simmons with his
his thing or
you know
any of the gracies like it just it just
became like family and then i just work
hard and deliver on what i say i'm going
to do if i say i'm going to do it i do
it
you know and i think it goes a long way
well and i got a comment so in a small
way i've uh people may not know i think
it's still on youtube we previously
talked many years ago and i remember
it uh you were so kind to me and you
didn't really know who i was you just
took me as a human being
you welcomed me into your dojo and we
just had a conversation on a podcast or
whatever the heck you call that thing
and you were just very kind and
and you were also just
it was the last conversation i had when
i showed up to mit in a stayed with me
so i've resumed doing this podcast but
it stayed with me because you said
you said that i did a good job at this
and people especially at that time
didn't tell me that
you know didn't and just that that
little act of kindness is probably just
a regular part of your day you had a
busy day it was the end of the day just
saying that
that was powerful and and that pays off
somehow um so thank you for that yeah
but i was sincere right it was genuine i
felt like i had been to so many
interviews when it's around the olympic
time there's lots of beat reporters that
come out and they're trying to get your
time and they're just
they're there because they have to get
the story yeah for their newspaper or
their television show and a lot of times
those people show up right and
they pronounce my name wrong or they get
something wrong about the background or
they offend me because they call me five
minutes before that they're supposed to
be there and say oh sorry we're running
late we'll be there an hour and a half
well i'm a busy guy too and you know
like yeah you were somebody that showed
up
was so prepared with your notes knew
everything about like the history of
what i had done
the questions you asked were intelligent
questions they were well thought out and
at the end of that that interview i was
really genuinely impressed
and i wanted to let you know you did a
great job because you stood out from the
rest thank you yeah i mean for me it was
like showing up to like the mecca like
the trash i mean i didn't you know you
don't always want to just tell that to
people but you show up
you know of obviously you're the legend
of judo in the united states and so that
was like boston is the mecca
i think that's where you travel
uh to talk to the great so um the the
fact that you were kind to me just stuck
with me for a long time so it pays off
to to to be kind to others to give them
to give them uh
to give them a chance jimmy thank you so
much for giving me another chance and
spending your valuable time and you've
also were kind enough to invite me to
train with you today
at your dojo so i can't wait let's go
let's go do some judo yeah awesome thank
you lex
you